Diddilidilididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididid Projekt mit mir. Mein Name ist Stefan T. Titzler und mir gegenüber sitzt der wunderbare und fantastische T-Schlürfende Florentin Will. Alles klar, viel Spaß bei der Folge. Ja, da bleibt ja wohl nicht mehr viel übrig, was wir zu sagen haben. Jetzt kommentieren sich, also es ist ja schon häufig vorgekommen, dass sich Intros selber kommentieren, jetzt kommentieren sie den Anfang, der oft nach Intros einsetzt. Ist das auch noch Teil des Intros gerade? Ich glaube schon. Und jetzt viel Spaß bei der Folge. Und jetzt kommt das Intro. Aber es ist jetzt so viel Meta-Edenen, dass ich gar nicht mehr weiß, wie ich darauf reagieren soll. Aber vielen Dank. Das haben Alex und Flo richtig gut gemacht, da haben sie sich was ausgedacht. Sehr, sehr schön. Ansonsten herzlich willkommen zu dieser Ausgabe. Ich glaube, wir haben mal wieder was halbwegs rundes, 360. Heute die 360-Grad-Folge, heute mal ein Rundumschlag in alle Richtungen. 60 mal 60. Korrekt, ja. Wir haben schon, hältst du lieber rückblickend, 60 mal 60 Folgen im Stück aufgenommen, um es dann wegzuhaben, oder lieber wie wir gemacht haben, so Pi mal Daumen wie mal eine Woche. Ich glaube, 60 Folgen am Stück sind schon ein ordentliches Drum am Stück. Das habe ich nicht gesagt, das ist nicht viel, äh, wenig. Ja, es stimmt, aber man hätte halt mehr Zeit gehabt dazwischen, ne? Aber ich glaube, es finde ich schon ganz in Ordnung, Rückblick hier. Also Rückblickend bereue ich nichts. Rückblickend bereue ich nichts. Also ich meine, ich will nicht arrogant wirken, aber so auf meinem Toten Bett. Komm, komm noch mal näher, Katharina, Katharina. Das klingt jetzt wie ein anemalen Kantereizung. Komm noch mal näher, Katharina, komm noch mal wieder zu mir ran. Komm mal wieder runter, Katharina. Katharina, deine Sorgen, interessiere mich nur peripher! Aufgewachsen und reingekommen! Aber das ist jetzt, das klingt wirklich... Nee, das ist mein Tod, meine letzten Worte. Die möchte ich jetzt nicht mit Anne-Mein-Kantereit verwechselt haben. Ich wünsche mir für meine Beerdigung, dass Anne-Mein-Kantereit nicht auftritt. What, eine Ausladung zur Beerdigung? Das ist mein einziger testamentarischer Wunsch, Doch, ich möchte. Aber du weißt ja jetzt nicht, ob ihr euch noch vielleicht. Ich habe nur einen Wunsch, Katharina, bitte. Ich habe nur einen Wunsch. Ich habe nur einen Wunsch, Katharina. Aber wie gemein. Dass sie nicht singen an meinem Grab. Aber wie gemein, jemanden auszuladen, weil du weißt ja nicht, ob du nochmal dich mit Henning May oder ich weiß nicht, wie die anderen mit Vornamen heißen, Kante oder Reit anfreundes nochmal. Ich schließe es fast aus, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Nicht, dass ich die drei Jungs nicht sympathisch finde, aber ich glaube einfach räumlich, man läuft sich nicht über den Weg. Die Welt ist dann doch zu groß. Kölner, nicht? Ja, aber auch Köln ist ein grosser, grosser Ort mit vielen, vielen Brücken. Und dann sagen wir auf der Brücke und dann meinen die die eine und die die andere. Und dann trinkt man sich nicht und zack, komm, lass das sein. Was soll's, was soll's, was soll's in Syrls. Laden wir sie direkt mal aus zu beenden. Laden wir sie direkt mal aus. Es wäre mein grosser Wunsch und es wäre mir wirklich ein Gram, wenn sie dann doch sängen. Aber ansonsten in meinem Totenbett, ich bereue nichts, ich habe alles, ich habe alles richtig gemacht und im Raum so eine, okay, Opa, ja, okay. Ich habe alles richtig gemacht. Und im Raum so eine ... Okay, Jesus, Logan, Roy. Okay, ja, okay. Ich habe alles genau richtig gemacht. So, wie ich es wollte. Okay, ja, gut. Er war bescheiden. Er war bei der Beerdigung, er war ein bescheidener Kerl. Ich freue mich, dass du da bist wieder. Das ist übrigens Florentin Will, der hier sitzt. Ist korrekt, ja, das hat das Intro dann doch richtig gemacht. Hat es dann doch richtig gemacht. Mir gegenüber Stefan Judokostice. Stefan. Der Stefan. Der Stefan. Langsam hat das F zum V, das ist die FV-Verschiebung, die können wir mittlerweile überall in der Sprache beobachten. Und auch bei Stefan sehen wir das, also immer mehr zu Stefan. Stefan. War mal meine erste E-Mail-Adresse, war stefan-at-web.de mit drei W fürs World Wide Web. stefan-at-web.de. Schreibt da mal hin, Gruß raus, geht an dieses, das ist auch so ein Limbo, einfach diese Mail, diese ersten Mailadressen, die man hatte, wo niemand mehr das Passwort hat. Ich weiß es nicht. Falls ihr niemanden habt, dem ihr schreiben könnt, schreibt Stefan. Stefan at workday. Schreibt der World Wide Web Seelsorge, schreibt einfach Stefan, eure tiefsten Geheimnisse. Vielleicht werden sie irgendwann mal ausgepackt und ausgegraben oder so und wir lesen sie dann witzig, mit witzigen Stimmen. Mit witzigen Stimmen lesen wir sie dann im Podcast vor. Dafür sind wir bekannt. Lustige Stimmen. Unsensibler Umgang mit euren Problemen. Dafür sind wir bekannt. Aber ich finde das tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht. Stefan mit drei W. Atweb.de. Gibt es die Domain noch? Stefan? Stefan? Weiß ich gar nicht. Wie die Domain? Stefan.com. Stefan.de. Nee, braucht es auch nicht geben. Es muss auch nicht alles geben. Es gibt ja diese Rule 74, nein, ich weiss die Zeile nicht mehr genau, dass alles, was es gibt, im Internet auch mit Porn gibt. Ja. Und irgendwie ist das ja auch quasi analog, alles gibt es im Internet. Und ich bin der Meinung, das reicht jetzt auch mal. Das ist genug. Weil es braucht jetzt nicht die Domain stefan.de. Du sagst deckeldrauf.de, oder was? Leute, deckeldrauf.de, ja. Es reicht. Heißt das, es gibt dann auch Porn zu uns, oder was? Oder würde es die Regel direkt widerlegen? Nee, es ist die Frage, wie definierst du Porn? Ich glaube, es gibt sicherlich Fanfictions über uns. Und das fällt ja schon manchmal in diese Richtung. Warum ist Fanfiction immer sexuell? Gute Frage, gute Frage. Da müssen wir natürlich jetzt mit den Leuten reden, die Fanfiction machen. Das ist vielleicht so das, was ausgeklammert wird, in diesen ganzen Filmen. Man denkt sich, die müssen doch auch ... Ja, geht, ehrlich gesagt. Na ja, gut, jetzt irgendwie Herr der Ringe oder so. Wird gefickt. Wo, nirgendwo. Die haben nicht mein Wort. Ich hab mir extra ein elbisches Wörterbuch gekauft und wollte natürlich erst mal irgendwie Titten und Penis nachschlagen. Beischlaf. Dann gab es gar nichts.
Nichts, nicht mal ein Wort dafür, nicht mal eine Andeutung,
irgendwas in der Richtung, gar nichts.
Okay, das stimmt.
Das sind die großen Franchises Pirates, The Rings, The Rings of the Powers und Harry Potters.
Herr Professor Tolkien, Sie gelten seit vielen, vielen Jahren
als einer der weltweit renommiertesten Linguisten.
Sie haben mehrere Sprachen selbst geschafft und so etwas wie einen modernen Mythos geschaffen. Lass Sie mich kurz an meiner Pfeife rauchen. Gerne. Sie haben so etwas wie den modernen Mythos geschaffen, eine, ja, Mythologie, die England immer vermisst hat, haben sie ihr gegeben. Mythos wird zur Legende wird. Ich kriege es nicht mehr genau zusammen. Geschichte wird zur … na ja. Sie lassen Ihre Bücher für sich sprechen, Herr Professor Tolkien. Ich habe allerdings eine Frage in Ihrer Sprache, Sindarin, die Elbensprache, Jahrtausende, alt, uralt, was heisst Penis? Entschuldigung, haben Sie gerade ... Schwanz, Dongle, also was ... Ich dachte, Sie wollten mir über meine Werke sprechen und irgendwie ... Genau, eine in sich schlüssige Welt, eine Sprache, die ihresgleichen sucht an Komplexität, aber den Schwanz, den suche ich vergeben. Was, schlägt das irgendwie in so eine Richtung ein hier, die ich nicht so ganz nachvollziehe? Weil ich wollte immer auch Familienromanisch schreiben. Also jetzt so ein Elb und eine Elbin, also wie, also wie, also was würden die denn sagen, schnachseln? Naja, ich glaube, das spielt ja keine Rolle in der Welt, die ich erzählen will. Ja, aber die Sprache existiert nur für die Geschichte, die Sie erzählen wollen? Naja, nein, das stimmt jetzt so nicht. Ich wollte natürlich eine allgemeinwürdige Sprache erfinden, die sich daraus in die Welt übertragen kann. Herr Professor, warum führen Sie die Adler ein ... Warum schwitze ich, können Sie die Fenster aufmachen? Wir können für die Akustik leider kein Fenster. Wenn jetzt die Adlerfrage kommt, wenn jetzt die Drecksadlerfrage kommt. In Isengard holt Gandalf die Adler mit der Motte. Muss diese Lampe in mein Gesicht gerichtet sein? Es tut mir leid, das brauchen wir für das Fotoshooting gleich im Anschluss. Warum fliegen die Gefährten nicht einfach mit den Adlern zum Schicksalsberg? Oh, Herr Professor, Herr Professor, Herr Professor, sollen wir sie in Karbonit einfrieren? Ein Spächen, was? Falsches Franchise. Okay. Ein Stechen in meiner Brust. Nein, der Ring, in seiner Brust steckt eine Klinge Morguls. Und dann hat sich Tolkien totgestellt. Sechs Jahre lang. Sechs Jahre lang, weil er sich diesen blöden, oder noch besser, es kam der Legende nach, der zum Mythos Schleschgeschichte wurde, kam ein Adler rein, kam dann ein Adler, den er ja in Akt 1 eingeführt hat und hat ihn aus diesem Studio gegriffen und weggetragen, aber dann in den Schicksalsberg geworfen. Und man denkt sich, hä? Und der Legende nach ist er so verschwunden, es gab nie eine Beerdigung. Beerdigung gab's nicht, ausser ... ... an der Mann kann Kankereit haben. Dolkin! Ich, äh, ja, ich find's nicht schlecht. Also bei mir würde ich ganz ehrlich sagen, würde ich gerne Einladung aussprechen. Bono ist klar. Mein Kamperite sollen da gerne spielen. Und Bono. Oh, wirklich? Ja. Ja, okay. Was ist, wenn wir jetzt zusammensterben und wir so eine Tandembeerdigung machen, und dann ist Anne-Meikandereit gleichzeitig eingeladen und ausgeladen. Dann haben wir so einen Paradoxon. Ich hab neulich gedacht, Menschen winken ja gerne auf Booten. Wenn Leute am Rhein zum Beispiel auf so einem Schiff vorbeifahren oder Elbe oder was auch immer, you name it, you name die Flüsse, die kennen wir alle. Da fahren sie drauf rum und dann winkt man am Strassenufer und die Leute lieben das ja. Auf Booten winken Menschen wieder zurück, wohingegen in der Straße oft Verwunderung. Ja. Meinst du mich? Meinst du mich oder meinst du mich? Also so, das ist die reine Reaktion. Auf Boten, der ist bewusst zurückgewunken. Und neulich ist ein Tandem an mir vorgegangen. So ein Ringring, süsses Bild, Tandem, Pärchen drauf. Und ich habe irgendwie den Impuls gehabt zu winken. Ich weiß nicht, was in mich gefahren ist, aber ich habe irgendwie dieses Bootgefühl gehabt, so, was soll schon schiefgehen. Aber beide waren eher genervt. Also haben nicht zurückgewunken.
Gar nicht zurückgewunken, weirde Blicke, Double Take.
Aber warst du nicht so ein Hilfe, ich ertrinke, weites Winken oder eher so ein ...
Nee, ach guck mal, ihr fahrt auf einem lustigen Gefährt, auf einem eher unüblichen Gefährt herum.
Das hast du alles mit deiner Hand ausgedrückt?
Ich habe versucht, das auszudrücken.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut es rüberkam, den Blick nachzuurteilen gar nicht.
Ich glaube aber eher, dass man unterschätzt, wie anstrengend ein Tandem ist und Theorie seitdem, einer ruht sich aus. Ja, klar. Einer ruht sich zu so einem Grad aus, dass der andere keinen Spaß hat, ist aber nicht, dann ist es wie ein Pärchen, dann ist es wie ein lustiges, lustiges Date-Idee oder sowas. Und dann kann der nicht sagen, aber du trammelst ja gar nicht. Oder entweder, sie hatten dieses Gespräch gerade, als ich dann gewunken habe und beide so, oh Jesus Christ. Oder alle winken, auch eine Theorie, weil man denkt, oder alle thematisieren das und irgendwann nervt es schlicht. Ja, ich finde, Tandem ist ein gutes Beispiel für verteilte Aufgabenteilung, weil natürlich, wer hinten sitzt, der muss nicht treten, weil der wird nicht gesehen vom anderen. Wenn der Vordere nicht tritt, sieht es der Hintere. Ich glaube, man kann das gut mit Traten. Meinst du das? Das war glaube ich nicht. Die Anspannung im Oberschenkel, die Spannung. Du siehst durch einen Jeans, durch eine drei Zentimeter dicke Jeans siehst du die Anspannung. Na ja, Tandem fährst du ja nicht im Winter. Da sind Shorts ein Thema, da sind Hotpants ein Thema, da sind die Beine gut sichtbar. Ich hab einen neuen Kink.
Will Florentin sagt Hotpants.
Das ist weird.
Also der Vorteil von, du sitzt hinten, dann musst du nicht treten.
Nachteil, du kannst dich lenken.
Wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt eine Hotpants trägst, und dann kann man auf jeden Fall sehen, brauchst du einen Moment, Stefan?
Du bist ja ganz weiß plötzlich geworden.
Ganz bleich bist du geworden.
Ich hätte das volle Bleich, wenn ich nicht aussehe.
Aber so, und das Problem ist, weil ich bin immer auf dem Tandem gefahren und war nicht die Frage hin oder vorne und ich dachte natürlich sofort straight hinten, weil ich natürlich nicht treten wollte.
Aber du hast hinten auch nochmal einen Lenker, aber da das Tandem schon älter war, war der Lenker nicht gerade. Der Lenker hatte keine Wirkung, nichts, das war nur das, was man sich festhält. Aber der war die ganze Zeit so gedreht, dass man denkt, man fährt nach links. Und dann gleich gewitzst du den die ganze Zeit? Ich hatte immer das Gefühl gehabt, ich fahre nach links, wollte mich nach links legen, ging nicht, weil die Person vorne wo ganz anders hingefahren ist. Das heißt, ich hatte quasi einen 90-minütigen Panikanfall, weil ich ständig dachte, ich falle um, ich falle um, ich falle um, Ich falle um, ich falle um, ich falle um, oh, ich falle um, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, doch langsam verstehen. Ja, aber tut er nicht. Das kennst du nicht, wenn man sehr betrunken ins Bett geht. Man hat das Gefühl, man fällt die ganze Zeit. Megagut. Und es ist nicht geil, weil es ist Panik, Panik, Panik, Panik. Und ich rede mir nicht immer selber ein, also nicht immer, als ob das häufig passiert, aber wenn es dann mal passiert, denkt man dann, ach, ich bin, aber, also ich fall ja nicht, Also ich fall ja nicht, denkt man sich, ich liege ja mal im Bett, das Tier und Boden, und dann ... Trotzdem kann man das Gefühl ja nicht überlisten. So stelle ich mir dann auch deine Panik vor. Rational sagt man sich, aber ich kipp ja schon seit einer Viertelstunde nicht um. Die Chance, dass ich umkippe in der nächsten Viertelstunde, ist ja relativ gering. Ja, aber das ist dem Körper egal. Der hat gesagt Panik, der drückt immer wieder auf den Knopf. Der drückt auf den Knopf. Das ist wie wenn man an der Tür klingelt und man sieht, auf der anderen Seite ist die Person schon da, man muss aufschliessen, aber du klingelst weiter. Sie sehen mich durchs Glas, ich bin schon da, aber das ist der klingelnde Person egal, Ding Dong, Ding Dong. Hat der unbegrenzt Panik oder ist es wie dieses Need for Speed Nitro, der Boost, der sich so aufladen muss. Nee, hat's nicht. Ich glaube, irgendwann ist schon gut, glaube ich. Irgendwann ist schon egal. Wie meinst du jetzt gut? Ja, irgendwann reicht's auch mal wieder. Ich glaube, du sturmst schon so ein bisschen ab. Du sturmst schon irgendwann ab. Ja, das glaube ich auch, ehrlich gesagt. Also das gab es ja letztens den Fall bei so einer Wasserrutsche, die ein Looping hatte. Und dann hat aber eine Frau den Looping nicht ganz geschafft und hing unten drin und kam nicht raus. Und dann hat, naja, wenn du den Looping vorstellst, dann musst du ja einmal eine gewisse Höhe erreichen, um weiterzukommen. Wenn du die nicht erreichst, dann fliegst du wieder zurück und bist unten drin und kommst nicht weiter und kannst dir da nicht hochlaufen. Bademeister hat Feierabend gemacht und die Frau hatte leider, leider ganz ungünstigerweise auch Platzangst. Und es war eine geschlossene. Es gab anscheinend eine Tür, mit der man hätte gehen können, aber die Frau hatte so eine Angst, dass das nicht funktioniert hat. Kann man nicht sagen, wenn der Bademeister Feierabend macht macht, schließen wir diese Looping- Todesmaschine? Den Deathmaster, den Deathmaster XX2 2000? Ja, das geht nicht. Ich weiß, deswegen kommen Leute zu uns ins Dialand. Für den Nackenbrecher und den Widmenmacher. Dafür kommen die Leute extra zu uns nach Wiesbaden und wollen die fahren. Er hat schon gegen seine Aufsichtspflicht verstoßen, wurde auch gefeuert, glaube ich. Das Problem war, die Frau war da drin eine Stunde lang ... Der Bademeister wurde gefeuert. Von wem? Ist die Frage. Wer steht in der Hierarchie über dem Bademeister? Wasser steht zumindest über dem Feuer, deswegen kannst du einen Bademeister schlecht feuern. Das heißt, da muss der Erdmeister ins Spiel kommen. Erd gewinnt gegen Wasser. Aus dem Erd ... ja. Oh, okay. Das war selbstbewusst gesagt. Oder Luft aber doch nicht. Das war so selbstbewusst von dir vorgetragen. Luft aber doch nicht. Ja. Luft aber doch nicht. So, und das Problem ist, die Frau war eine Stunde da drin und hatte anscheinend eine Stunde lang so viel Angst, dass sie nicht, also, kann das schlicht nachvollziehen. Aber da denke ich mir auch so, klar, wenn du Platzangst hast, ist das wahrscheinlich der absurde Albtraum. Aber klingt das gar nicht ab. Anscheinend war die eine Stunde lang nicht in der Lage, mal zu gucken, wo bin ich, gibt es eine Tür, sondern die hatte einfach eine Stunde lang durchgehend Panik. Und da denke ich mir schon, ist es so schlau, dass das nie aufhört. Vor allem, wir sind ja schon die ängstlichsten Versionen von Homo sapiens, sapiens, sapiens, sapiens. Ja, meinst du? Ja, weil ich Theorie, es haben immer die ängstlichsten überlebt. Ich glaube, inzwischen ist es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr der Fall, aber früher haben, glaube ich, die ängstlichsten unserer Vorfahren immer überlebt, weil die sich am ehesten in Schutz gebracht haben und sowas.
Also das kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das so ist. Und jetzt Problem, jetzt sind wir so weit fortgeschritten, dass wir Looping-Rutschen bauen. So, und da steht es uns irgendwie auch im Weg, kann man sagen. In gewisser Weise steht uns die Evolution im Weg. Weil wir so Panik haben, dass wir da nicht rauskommen dann, weil wir die Tür nicht finden, die groß mit dem X markiert ist. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite sollte man diese Rutsche auch nicht dann so, wenn man die serienmässig rausbringt, die gibt es ja wahrscheinlich serienmässig. Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht. Wie viele von diesen Rutschen gibt es? Ja, aber Serien. Reihen, Millionen. Du meinst, da gibt es eine in Amsterdam, eine in Wiesbrück, eine in Tokio, eine in Ulaanbatu, überall. The Panic Master 2000.
Panic Loop.
Ich glaube, dann wäre es doch sinnvoll, den so herzustellen,
dass es gar keine Option ist, dass du stecken bleibst.
Ja, gut, aber das ist natürlich auch der Thrill.
Die Todesangst fährt mit.
Bei der Achterbahn rutscht ja auch nicht die Todesangst mit. Ja, gut. Der das ist natürlich auch der Thrill, ne? Also die Todesangst fährt mit. Ja, aber bei der Achterbahn rutscht ja auch ...
Bei der Achterbahn fährt ja auch nicht die Todesangst mit.
Ja, gut.
Der Thrill fährt mit.
Der Thrill. Oder man spült einmal komplett durch,
bevor man Feierabend macht.
Dass man wie so eine Art Klospülung hat, dass man ...
Alle rausspült, die Stecken gewinnen sind.
Einmal alles rausspült, die ganzen Pflaster,
die ganzen irgendwie Badehosen, die da hängen geblieben sind.
Einfach mal einmal durchspülen.
Hotpants.
Zum Beispiel, ja? Nein, ich weiß nicht. Also, ganz schlimme Idee. Ich bin auch, ehrlich gesagt, ich war nie ein Spaßbart-Fan. Warst du ein Spaßbart-Fan? Ich fand auch schon immer, da bin ich an meine Grenzen gestossen. Es gab immer Rutschen, die noch zu hoch für mich waren, es gab immer noch Türme, die zu hoch für mich waren. Also, ich war in einem komfortablen Niveau, wo es nach oben und nach unten Platz gab. Ich bin so ein Drei-Meter-Brett-Typ. War mir auch schon zu hoch, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, ich habe versucht, einen Hecht zu machen, bin voll auf dem Rücken gelandet. Und da dachte ich mir, nee, das war's. Ich habe vor allem nie verstanden, was ist der spaßige Aspekt für viele Leute, vor einem Drei-Meter-Brett zu springen? Der, ich glaube, der Part, dass du nicht stirbst. Wenn du failst. Genau. Aber Fallen an sich fand ich jetzt auch schon nicht geil. Ich will gerne fallen. Ja, ich glaub, dieser kurze Moment, ah, ich bin tot, na, doch nicht, okay, cool. Das ist so, wie wenn ein Termin abgesagt wird, so, du denkst, oh, jetzt Beerdigung, Bestattung, hat jemand, hat Kante das Memo bekommen, dass die nicht auftreten? Kante mal anreiten. Und dann aber doch, ah, nee, passt schon. Aha. Ja, weil ich dachte, vielleicht ist es auch das Momentum des Eintauchens, was für viele vielleicht gewissen Nervenkitzel slash Fun auslöst. Aber ich glaube, du hast recht, es ist eher der Fall mit dem Wissen, ich überlebe das Ding. Ja, ich überlebe es. Ich weiß nicht. Keiner dieser Aspekte, weder oben zu stehen, dieser bevorstehende Nervenkitzel, noch das Fallen, noch das Eintauchen war für mich irgendwie interessant. Ich war mal während meiner Zivis im Schwimmbad mit den Kindern und ich hatte viel zu viel Spaß. Gott. Viel zu viel Spaß. Musst du nicht panisch am Rand stehen und sagen, wo ist Hendrik, wo ist Hendrik, wo ist Hendrik, Hendrik taucht auch. Aber es gibt so eine Rangliste an Kindern und bei der untersten Kategorie sagt man, wir gehen kein Risiko ein, wir schnallen denen einfach so einen Ring um den Bauch, dass die unmöglich untergehen können. Also selbst wenn die nach unten gezogen werden von einem Hai, das hat einfach zu viel Kraft nach oben, das hat genug Auftrieb. Also da geht man kein Risiko ein. Das heißt, die schlechtesten Schwimmer sind immun gegen alles, eigentlich die mittleren sind eher das Problem, die gut schwimmen können, aber sich vielleicht übernehmen, aber wie mal das eher ist, egal, weil ich hab ein Salto gemacht vom Einser, mega geil, Alter, das hat mega Spaß gemacht und die anderen Erzieher so, ja, guck mal, und ich dachte mir, fuck, ich würde jetzt gerne lieber ein Salto machen. Ein Salto? Ich hab ein Salto vom Einser gemacht, Alter, war mega. Das passt überhaupt gar nicht zu dir. Mega geil, doch, ja, ich weiß, und deswegen, ich dachte auch so, ja, okay, gut, musst du aufpassen auf die Kinder, wird schon. Aber dann hatte ich plötzlich so unerwartet viel Spaß. Also wenn man merkt, das macht gerade viel zu viel Spaß. So wie wenn du im Wald so Steine in den See wirfst und dir denkst, holy shit, macht das gerade Spaß. Das sollte nicht so viel Spaß machen. Das ist so, Alter, das ist gerade das Geilste, was es gibt. So, ich glaube, Leute, die selbstbewusst im Schwimmbad sind, die selbstbewusst und cool im Schwimmbad sind, ich glaub, die, das ist ganz einzeln übertragen auf soziale Hierarchie in der Schule. Ja. Weil es waren immer die Leute am coolsten im Schwimmbad, die, keine Ahnung, so natürliche Selbstbewusstsein hatten, natürlich auch irgendwie sportlich waren und sowas. Also die, so eine, Leute, die sich da als wäre es ein natürlicher Lebensraum verhalten haben, waren auch die coolsten in der Schule. Total, die sich wohl gefühlt haben, wenn sie nicht alle Kleidung anhaben. Ja, ja, genau. Und dann gab es natürlich die Taucher. Und ich war natürlich direkt der Taucher. Ich wollte immer gut tauchen können, damit ich möglichst lange nicht gesehen werde, der nicht gut tauchen kann. Und dann war ich im Tauchkurs und ich konnte auch mal die Diagonale tauchen im Schwimbecken. Nein! Nein! Und deswegen möchte ich sagen rückblickend, ich habe nichts falsch gemacht. Weil ich konnte mal die Diagonale tauchen im Schwimmbad. Hätte ich's nicht gemacht, hätte ich's bereut. Wenn du dran geblieben wärst, hätte ich's ja mehr richtig gemacht. Ich glaube, hätte ich das damals nicht durchgezogen, hätte ich's bereut. Aber so bereue ich gar nichts. Gar nichts? Nee.
Weil wir jetzt nur über diese Diagonale sprechen im ...
Je ne regrette rien.
Okay, Sie sprechen noch nicht so gut Französisch.
Aber gut genug.
Auch da bereuen Sie nichts.
Nichts, überhaupt nichts.
Sie hätten auch andere Sprachen lernen können. Sprachen, die vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Relevanz haben in der Welt.
Zum Beispiel?
Mandarin.
Sie bereuen ... Also, nö, ehrlich gesagt nicht. Okay. Nee, beruhig nicht. Ciao. Ja, vielen Dank fürs Interview. Nächste Woche zu Gast. Der Mensch, der noch nie Angst hatte. Es bleibt dabei. Ich bin immer irritiert. Gute Radiosender. Aber Sie müssen auch vor irgendwas Angst haben. Nö. Hä? Ich als Moderator immer irritiert verwundert. Finde ich aber gar nicht schlecht, eine Sendung nur um Stefan zu verwirren. Einfach nur. Hä? Die bräunen gar nichts. Und wir haben noch nie was anderes gegessen außer Brot. Nö. Hä? Sie müssen doch was anderes essen. Nö. Und man kann immer meine Sätze austauschen.
Sie müssen doch schon mal XYZ.
Aber Sie haben doch noch nie XYZ?
Ja.
Aber Ihre Familie muss doch XYZ.
Ich könnte mir das nicht vorstellen, niemals.
Genau, aber zumindest mal aus Versehen zu.
Ja, ist Ihnen mal nicht was in den Mund gefallen an Karneval oder so?
Nee, tatsächlich nicht.
aber es ist Genau, aber zumindest mal aus Versehen zu. Ja, ist sie mal nicht was in den Mund gefallen an Karneval oder so? Nee, tatsächlich nicht. Aber sie waren dem auch nie im Fernsehen mal ausgesetzt. Es ist so interessant. Sie waren niemals mal bei einer Kochshow, wo man dann Essen bekommen hat, wo das gekocht wurde oder so. Nee. Die große Irritationsshow. Wenn die das Essen, das sie in der Kochshow kochen würden, einfach so ins Publikum werfen, aber einfach wie so einem Kuhstall, einfach so reinwerfen, wie so dieses Lachsfilet mit Reis, mit Wildreis, und es wird dann genommen, einfach so mit der Hand, greift Ralf Zacherl einfach in dieses Filet und das Publikum mit so nach oben gereckten Mündern wie so kleine Vögel. Wir versuchen es einfach aus der Laufsäße. Ich finde es aber auch gut, wenn er sehr nah vor dieser Person steht, die er bewirft. Und er mit diesem Lachsfilet, so viel zu hart, er steht so eineinhalb Meter von Brigitte entfernt und ballert er das in die Fresse. Und die aber atmen, atmen, atmen, atmen, atmen, und er drückt so einer alten Frau so in den Mund rein, einfach so ganz zärtlich. Bei Kochshows dauern die wahrscheinlich ewig. Ja. Wie ein Gericht zu kochen. Ja, absolut. Ich habe auch gedacht, wie sauer man, also nicht sauer, aber wie man im Restaurant, wenn das Essen nicht kommt, so nach einer halben Stunde, werden Leute ab und zu schon mal so ein bisschen horchen auf. Und dann kommt schon mal so ein, aber die muss vergessen, das Essen kommt nicht. Und man denkt, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben, war ich schneller als eine halbe Stunde bei irgendeinem Gericht. Ja, never. Selbst eine fünf Minuten Terrine ist locker Nachmittag. Bis ich die Pfannen rausgeholt habe und so und dann, ach jetzt jetzt kommt da Öl und blablabla. Bis der Herd aufgeheizt ist, ist schon eine halbe Stunde rum. Ja, ich bin... Und man hat bei Restaurants so einen Anspruch, dass die wahnsinnig schnell ihre Gerichte rausballern. Es dauert viel zu lange. Ich bin jetzt tatsächlich wieder ein bisschen auf dem Koch. Ich bin gerade wieder, ich heiz mal vor, so sei mal. Und jetzt, was ich mir dachte, was ich lernen möchte, ist karamellisierte Zwiebeln. Grundlage muss man können. Und dachte ich, das übe ich mal, das kann man als Grundlage für viele tolle Sachen benutzen. Und dann schaue ich Videos an und die ersten zwei Videos, die ich anschaue, war Video eins, sagt der Koch, ja, kleiner Tipp von mir, Sie können Salz in die Zwiebeln streuen. Dad dadurch wird die Flüssigkeit rausgesaugt und dadurch wird es schneller irgendwie so knusprig oder halt so schleimig schlotzig. Zweites Video, mein Tipp ist, Sie kippen einfach ein Glas Wasser dazu, damit die Zwiebeln schneller durch sind und es schneller geht. Der denkt mir, so wisst ihr was, ich gucke in fünf Jahren nochmal, ob ihr euch fucking geeinigt habt oder lassen wir es einfach, weil da habe ich keinen Bock drauf, dass zwei das exakte Gegenteil sagen und allein da Salz, weil Salz zieht die Flüssigkeit raus und wo ist die dann, also ja genau, das ist doch albern, also was soll das heißen, Körper, sagt man, wenn man viel Salz isst, hat man ja Durst. Daher kommt das, glaube ich. Aber das ist ja ein komplexeres System, in dem du Salz zuführst, das wird dann irgendwie verarbeitet, blablabla, keine Ahnung, da verstehe ich das, wo das Wasser hingeht auf eine Art. Auch nicht so richtig. Wenn du mir eine Frage stellst, bricht das gerade noch zusammen, aber wenn es in eine Pfanne haus Salz, wo soll das Wasser hingehen schneller? Ich habe das schon so oft gehört. Ja, Salz zieht die Flüssigkeit aus. Ja, aus dem Körper. Ja, aber dieses Wort ziehen impliziert ja, dass es danach irgendwo ist. Also das verschwindet ja nicht. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung. Das kann man auch gut vorstellen. Absoluter Quatsch. Absoluter Nonsens. Und wo ist der Koch jetzt, der Salz auf Dinge kippt, damit es, also ich glaube auch nicht, dass der weit kommt, weil erstmal glaube ich alles versalzen, weil Wasser willst du ja nicht selten in Gerichten haben, ausser bei so einer Suppe, so einer schönen Suppe. Ja, ja. Aber es gibt ja auch so einen Koch, also so ein alter Fernsehkoch, einer der ersten, als dann so Kameras am Start waren und Fernsehproduktion, der hat das Deutscher, der hat das Toast Hawaii erfunden.
Echt?
Und er hat viele Sachen behauptet.
Er hat immer gesagt, er war irgendwie auf Weltreisen und dann war er im persischen Landen.
Und dann hat er dann da das und das gesehen.
Er hätte man schon stutzig werden können bei der Wahrheit seiner Angaben.
Komische Sachen immer erzählt.
Und dann war ein Reiter und der gab ihm das und das, alles albern.
Und am Ende hat er nur erfunden die Erdbeere, wo er oben das Gehäuse rausgemacht hat und einen Mandel reingeschoben hat. Die gefüllte Erdbeere und so was. Und er hat auch das Toast … Die jetzt gar nicht mal so populär ist, oder? Null, also hat sich auch nicht durchgesetzt. Habe ich auch nie gehört. Gegenüber der normalen Erdbeere zum Beispiel. Mandeln, cool, Erdbeeren, cool. Zusammen? Ne, ne, ne.
Aber so, und er hat auch das Toasterwey erfunden.
Irgendwann hat sich aber ein anderer Fernsehkoch,
der war aber weniger bekannt,
immer gegen den gestellt.
Und so stelle ich mir auch ein bisschen diese beiden,
den Salz rein.
Da gab es so eine Feindschaft zwischen denen.
Und dann sind auch Geldbeträge geflossen,
weil der eine hat dann dem anderen
immer so Vorwürfe gemacht, das hat er von ihm geklaut.
Und dann hat er ja mal eine Call-In-Show gehabt, der gefüllte Erdbeeren-Guy. Und da hat jemand ihn wohl irgendwie auch gesagt, das kann doch niemand, das hat doch nicht erfunden, das machen doch irgendwie Leute, weiß ich nicht, in Südostasien, und das ist schon die ganze Zeit, füllen Erdbeeren mit Mandeln. Und dann hat er literally sich dieses große Küchenmesser an seine Kehle gehalten und gesagt, wenn jetzt noch einer anruft, der behauptet, ich hätte das nicht erfunden und einen Beweis vortragen kann, einen Beweis vortragen kann, dann schlitze ich mir die Kehle auf. Und das war, das war damals Fernsehen. Und dann hat er gesagt, und, meldet sich noch einer? Nein? Okay, dann können wir weitermachen. Das war damals die Stimmung in Koch-Fucking-Koch-Sendungen. Es war nicht, es war nicht irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Das war noch eine Küchenschlacht. Das war wirklich noch was. Das war eine literal Küchenschlacht. Wie schlimm ist es? Wahnsinn. Und dann hat natürlich niemand in diesen zwei Sekunden rhetorischer Pause angerufen. Weil man damals auch irgendwie in den nächsten Ort fahren musste, um ein Telefon zu finden. Ja. Also das war jetzt nicht das beste Comeback. Es war gar kein gutes Comeback. Alles daran war, aufgeladen hochtausend. Er hat sich dann nicht umgebracht. Alles merkwürdig. Aber ich finde das sehr cool, wenn alles, was du im Leben erreicht hast, mal eine Mandel in eine Erdbeere zu stecken und zu sagen, das ist meins. Und eine Ananas auf den Toast zu legen. Ja, das ist ja viel besser. Eben. Hawaii ist ja genial, Toast Hawaii. Locker auch nicht von ihm. Aber das ist genial, weil da finde ich, da ist er wiederum der deutschen Küche auch weit voraus, mal was Süßes mit was Herzhaftem kombinieren. Total. Die Ananas, ich meine, klar, ist inzwischen ein Meme, so diese Ananas auf der Pizza und sowas, auf dem Toast. Ja, aber das ist ja wahre Kunst. Wahre Kunst muss ja die Menschen spalten, muss sie ja bewegen, muss sie ja aufrühren. Wahre Kunst muss die Menschen spalten? Schinken, Formfleisch auf der Pizza, mein Gott, das kann ja jeder. Aber die Ananas, die man wirklich spaltet, Säure mit reinbringt, man neue Welten mit reinbringt, man die Palette aufmacht, wow. Die Erfindung des Toast Hawaii wird allgemein dem Fernsehkoch Clemens Wilmenrod zugeschrieben, der ihn 1955 in Deutschland erstmals vorstellte. Vermutlich übernahm Wilmenrod das Rezept jedoch von seinem Konkurrenten und Lehrer Hans Karl Adam. Und der ist immer hinten rübergefallen. Und die beiden hatten diesen Krieg. Ich finde das total geil. Sein, Wasser, nein. Ist das eine Serie? Ja. Oder ein Podcast? Oder so ein kleines Büchlein, so ein Trolley, so eine Packung Trolley-Fruchtgummis oder irgendwas.
Irgendein Medium wird es sein.
Jede Geschichte ist für irgendein Medium perfekt.
Für so eine Bahndurchsage vielleicht.
So ein Funfact-Plakat an der Bahn.
Hier steht, aufgrund der Zusammenstellung der Zutaten besitzen der Toast Hawaii und ähnlich zusammengesetzte Gerichte das Potenzial zur Bildung von krebserregenden Nitrosaminitriten. Nitrosamititriten? Es ist krebserregend. Hier steht, es gibt ein Absatz Krebsrisiko in dem Wikipedia-Artikel, das locker von Hans-Karl Adam hat gesagt. Genau, schreiben Sie das mal da rein. Aber auch nur in der Zusammensetzung, also nicht die einzelnen Komponenten sind krebserregend, sondern Ananas plus Schinken gleich Krebs. Nee, nee, nee, die Ananas macht's. Die Ananas macht's, pass auf. Nämlich die Zusammensetzung des Nitriten im Pökelsalz, des Schinkens und den Aminosäuren des Käses im sauren Milieu der Ananas. Also genau diese drei Zutaten ergeben Tod. Das ist ja wirklich Schinken plus Käse plus Ananas gleich Krebs. Genau, die Nitrite im Pökelsalz des Schinkens, den Aminosäuren des Käses und das alles im sauren Milieu. Milieu ist fantastisch. Aber ein sehr unwissenschaftliches Wort. In der sauren Gegend, ja? Der Ananas. Ananas. Wahnsinn. Aber ich meine, es macht es jetzt, finde ich, noch interessanter, weil es eine verbotene Frucht jetzt. Ananas ist jetzt eine verbotene Frucht, die noch sicher ist. Ich habe jetzt so Bock auf Toast Hawaii. Ey, total. Aber jetzt hat es ja was von Rauchen, also was selbsterstörerisches, cooles. Ja, genau, was cooles, was fetziges. Ich stelle mal vor, Leute würden in so einem alten Film, so einem Noir-Film Toast-Ananas-Hawaii essen und nicht rauchen. Und dann die Eltern so zu ihren Kindern, das machen wir heute nicht mehr. Hach mich mal an, hach mich mal an. Mama, warum denn? Ich rieche doch Ananas. Quatsch, nein. Ich rieche doch Ananas, Hans. Nein, nein, nein, mein Gott, hinter der Turnhalle haben wir einen halben Hawaii gesnackt. Mein Gott, stell dir doch nicht so an. Brigitte, komm mal her. Was denn? Weißt du, was unser Sohn macht? Nein. Hat heute ein halbes Toast Hawaii gegessen. Hans! Das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Ich hab gedacht. Die Nitrite im Säu... Im Milieu. Nochmal, liest du nochmal vor. Die Nitrite im Pökelsalz, die Aminosäuren des Käses, ergeben im ganzen Milieu... Ergeben im sauren Milieu der Ananas. Das haben wir ja wirklich schon hundertmal gesagt. Das haben wir selber schon. Mann, du doch den Schinken weg. Eines von drei muss doch entbehrlich sein, Hans!
Lass doch irgendwas davon weg!
Du musst ja nur eins! Es ist ja nur ein Puzzlestück!
Was ist denn an Ananas mit Käse so schlecht? Oder an Schinken Käse?
Aber ehrlich gesagt, das zeigt mir jetzt wieder, weil das macht sehr geil.
Diese drei Sachen machen sehr geil. Käse und Ananas?
Es scheint doch irgendeine Kombu zu sein, dass das so funktioniert. Das ist doch kein Zufall. Welche Zutat würdest du am ehesten weglassen? Ananas. Sorry. Ja. Nee, aber ich mein, klar, Käse, Schinken, boring. Aber gut. Schinken, Ananas, näh. Käse, Ananas, weird. Also es ist genau diese Zusammensetzung, die spannende.
Nee, ich brauch die Nitrite. Ich brauch einfach diese fucking Nitrite.
Ich brauch die Nitrite, ich brauch die Aminosäuren und das ganze Milieu des Auchen-Ananas. Und jetzt nitritfreien Schinken, das ist ja krass. Aber das macht für mich den Toast Hawaii noch cooler. Mich auch, mich auch. Vor allem, ich finde ja auch, der Toast Hawaii ist der einzige Toast, weil wir denken an Schinkenkäse-Sandwich, wir denken an ein Grill-Cheese-Sandwich. Lass mich das kaputt machen kurz. Croc Monsieur. Oh la la Monsieur, treibia, treibia. Aber ich bin auch nur darauf gekommen, weil es hier auch namentlich erwähnt wird. Aber es gibt kein Hawaii-Sandwich. Also man würde nie einen Toast Hawaii als Sandwich machen. Das wäre absoluter Freve, da würde man sagen, nein. Albern fände ich das. Das wäre einfach Krebs zwischen zwei Brothälften, das würde überhaupt nicht funktionieren. Das wäre zu viel Krebs. Da wächst dir noch das Geschwür aus der Nase raus, während du es isst, wirklich. Das ist ja interessant. Aber das ist ja wichtig, die dümmste Art, Krebs zu kriegen, oder? Also ich meine, das ist wirklich mit Abstand dümmste Art. Also es ist immer dumm, aber es ist immer bedauerlich. Aber von allen Dingen ... Warum, er hat doch nie geraucht. Hat man in meiner Krebsdiagnose auch gesagt, wodurch genau? Ja, steht dann ganz groß auf so einem Schild. Also Auslöser ... Wieso, kannst du dir vorstellen, wenn am Flughafen abgeholt wird von jemandem, da steht dann das Schild der Name drauf. Und da gibt es dann irgendwann so eine Präsentation im Krankenhaus, wenn du Krebs hast. Da ist erst so ein Kreppband drüber und das wird dann abgezogen. Und der Täter ist Toast Hawaii. Toast Hawaii? Moment mal, ich habe vor 16 Jahren in Italien einmal einen Toast Hawaii gegessen. Ich fand ihn noch nicht mal lecker. Herr Doktor, also mein Mann hat nicht geraucht, er hat viel Sport gemacht, er hat sich gesund ernährt. Ja, ich verstehe, was Sie sagen, aber wissen Sie, das ist leider eine gefährliche Verbindung aus den Nitriten des Pökelfleischs, der Aminosäure des Käses und das zusammen im sauren Milieu der Ananas. Ich finde es gut, dass wir das inzwischen wissen, dass auswendig ist. Es gibt leider einen Krebs, es tut mir wirklich leid. Aber gibt es das noch in anderen Dingen? Weil es kann ja nicht einfach unmöglich nur diese Konstellation sein. Okay, welche andere Nahrungsmittel haben Nitrite, Aminosäuren in einem sauren Milieu? Centershock vielleicht. Aber das ist wenig überraschend. Dass die Dinger direkt aus der Hölle kommen, glaube ich, sollte jedem bewusst sein, der die mal gesehen hat. Das finde ich so wenig überraschend. Alles, wo man so ein Gesicht macht, so ein Centershock-Gesicht. Wo der Körper sagt, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, klar, natürlich. Ah, Pizza Hawaii, wegen Ananas. Jetzt verstehe ich es. Ist Ananas so richtig hawaiianisch? Ja. Also ich glaube, den Eindruck kann es schon erwecken, tropisch halt im Allgemeinen. Also ich glaube, das kann man schon sagen. Aber dann ist die Pizza Hawaii definitiv auch krebserregend, weil da sind die gleichen Zutaten auch drauf. Richtig, da sind auch Schinken drauf, alles im sauren Milieu der Ananas plus Aminosäuren des Käses. Und ich würde es wieder und wieder und wieder tun. Wahnsinn, ich finde das so fantastisch. Also diese ganze Geschichte ist sehr zu empfehlen, Clemens Wilmroth, der sich das Messer an die Kehle hängt. Rückblickend auch da nicht verwunderlich, dass er dieses Krebsding auf den Markt bringt. Und die gefüllte Erdbeere. Wie heißt sie denn? Also hat die Erdbeere nicht... Sie ist nur gefüllte Erdbeere. Sie ist auch so eine Erdbeere mit Fingernagel. Das ist einfach ganz unangenehm. Aber auf eine gewisse Weise auch ästhetisch, weil natürlich die Erdbeere ja an sich schon so kleine Mandeln am Rand stecken hat. Die Erdbeere ist ja eigentlich eine Nuss. Eigentlich ist es ja ein Nusssalat. Halt dein Maul. Biggest Red Flag. Erdbeere. Erdbeere ist ja eigentlich eine Nuss, ne? Ach Gott, halt dein dummes Maul. Halt dein Maul. Biggest Red Flag, biggest Red Flag. Erdbeere. Erdbeeren. Leute, die behaupten, Erdbeeren sind Nüsse. Aber gibt es keinen Namen für die gefüllte Erdbeere? Weil ich finde, gefüllt, da finde ich das zählt nicht, wenn du deine Mandel reinsteckst. Er hat auch Toast Hawaii erst mit Ananas belegtes Toast genannt. Er war ja nicht so der Namensguy. Also dafür, dass Toast Hawaii so ein cooler Name ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob es von ihm kommt. Gefüllte Erdbeere. Aber jetzt muss ich es echt mal ausprobieren. Das ist ja gerade Erdbeersaison, oder? Es gibt ja schon ein paar leckere Früchte. Es ist Erdbeer- und Mandelsaison. Saison, ja, gibt es eigentlich schon. Kannst du das schon mal dir reinstecken. Er hat auch arabisches Reiterfleisch für ein einfaches Hackfleischgericht, venezianischer Weihnachtsschmaus für panierte Schnitzel, aber auch päpstliches Huhn, Zwiebelsuppe René, flambeierte schwarze Banane und Würstchen mit Austern und viele weitere. Flambeierte schwarze Banane, jetzt hast du meine Aufmerksamkeit. Aber ganz ehrlich, er hat einfach nur Dinge kombiniert, die nicht zusammengehören. Feuer und Banane, Würstchen und Austern. Die noch nie zusammen gesehen wurden, ja. Aber das kann ich auch. Dann kann ich auch kochen. Gut, es ist ein bisschen so dieser alberne Satz, aber dieses Bild kann ich auch mal. Ja, wenn es schon gibt, dann kannst du es imitieren, ist ja klar. Nee, aber einfach zwei Tutan zusammenzuwerfen, die nicht zusammengehören, kann ich auch, wirklich. Das machst du die ganze Zeit. Centershocks und Erbsen, dein berühmtes Gericht. Die Hawaiianen, die die koreanische ...
Stepptänzerin.
Begegnung.
Die koreanische Handreichung.
Ich hätte gern einmal die koreanische Handreichung.
Der Berliner Dolchstoss.
Ist einfach, rückblickend ziemlich einfach.
Sehr gut.
Einfach Tomate und Zitrone.
Ja, das Gesicht machen alle. Ja, aber es hat was. Naja. Also, ja, albern. Ich finde das alles albern. Ich bin jetzt auch wieder kurz davor, abzudriften in den Alkoholismus, denn ich habe die Serie geschaut. Wieso wieder? Drops of God, neue Serie auf Apple TV, da geht es um Wein, Vino, Vino, Vino, und ich habe mir angeschaut, alle Folgen, die bis jetzt verfügbar sind, und da geht es viel um Wein und wie fucking lecker der ist, das ist eine komplette Serie, die nur Werbung dafür ist, wie fucking lecker Wein ist und wie unglaublich toll das ist, und ich sitze da mit meiner Cola Light und mein Lachgummi und stopfe mir die rein und drücke mir die rein. Und ich habe tatsächlich, während ich die Serie geschaut habe, weil die immer so mit Riechen und Identifizieren von Aromen und ah ja, Mandarine, Trockenfrucht, Holz, Kalk, ja, die haben dann immer diese ganzen Paletten. Und währenddessen dachte ich mir, naja gut, okay, aber ich kann die Lachgummis am Geschmack erkennen. Und am Ende war es so erbärmlich, dass ich die versucht habe, an der Form zu erkennen, als ich die gegessen habe. Aber du kannst nicht, ohne irgendwas mitzuspielen, dann diese Serie gucken. Du hast dann gesagt, zumindest errate ich jetzt ... Ja, zumindest errate ich die Lachgummis, aber ich musste mich dann selber betrügen, dass ich die nicht am Geschmack, sondern an der Form erkannt habe. Das Geile bei Wein ist ja auch, dass du halt so eine unendliche Welt hast, also weil das ja schon seit Jahrhunderten perfektioniert wird und so, dass du da wirklich, du kannst da die rein da, ich will jetzt auch nicht noch Werbung dafür machen, dass du jetzt irgendwie am Anfang das Alkohol so trinkst, gut, dass du es nicht machst, aber du isst halt auch Toast Hawaii und zerstörst deinen Körper von innen heraus selbst. Ich denk mir halt immer so, ich hab einen sehr erbärmlichen Geschmackssinn, ich mag billig, ich mag einfach billig, also gibt auch sehr billige Weine, also stell dich mir von einer Süßigkeitenregal vor, du hast Lind, du hast tolle Schokoladen, ich tendiere zu diesen zweimal zwanzig steinharten Zuckerkugeln in unterschiedlichen Formen, wie so diese Med diese Medikamentenpackungen in so Plastik, die man so rausdrücken muss von der anderen Seite. Zu denen tendiere ich. Das ist mein Go-To-Snack. Geil. Nicht irgendwie die Tüte, nicht mal Fred Ferkel, das ist für mich Ohlala, Ohlala, Le Ferkel, Chateau Ferkel. Und jetzt überlege ich, ob so diese Haute Couture des Weines, ob mich das richtig aus den Schuhen hauen würde, weil das so viel besser ist, oder ob ich es gerade nicht mögen würde, weil ich eigentlich eher das Billige mag. Ich habe neulich einen Weinfehler geschmeckt. Da war ich stolz, ja. Da war ich stolz. Ja, ist Strich vor Punkt, oder was ist das passiert? Geburtstag, große Runde, ein Kollege hat eingeladen, war ein schönes, gutes Restaurant, haben einen Wein bekommen und ich habe den irgendwie zum Probieren. Dann hatte sie so zwei Flaschen oder sowas und dann konnte jeder seinen Lieblingswein ausprobieren. Und dann habe ich dann einen bekommen und habe dann gesagt, oh, der ist aber weird. Und dann fand sie, die Kellnerin, wenn sie im Sommelier war, keine Ahnung, fand das so irritierend, diese Aussage, oh, der schmeckt aber weird, weil es war nur, ich fand es auch ein bisschen lecker, ehrlich gesagt,
kennt man ja, ich mag aber auch, so Benzingeruch mag ich auch, also manchmal, manchmal mag man,
Urin oder so, ja so, oder so ein Furz, erbrochenes, ja, manchmal, man findet ja auch darin,
oder so Pferdeäpfel riechen jetzt nicht, ja, ja, nee, ist für einen kurzen Moment, für so ein Lüftchen. Ja, versteh, was du meinst. Ich versteh das zumindest. Ja, ja. Und dann hab ich gedacht, das war weird. War nicht geil, aber ich fand's schon spannend. Und dann fand sie die Reaktion komisch, ist dann weggegangen und hat dann mit dem Kollegen, hab ich gesehen, haben diese Flasche, haben die probiert und so, und beide haben das durch ein Glas eingeschenkt und probiert und gerochen und sowas und haben beide wild gestikulieren miteinander gesprochen und dann kamen sie wieder zum Tisch und haben sich bei dem ganzen Tisch entschuldigt, dass dieser Wein überhaupt noch im Rennen war. Das war hoch peinlich. Und das fand ich so cool, dass ich dann... Warst du da der fucking coolste Badass am Tisch oder was? Ja, ich war der coolste fucking Badass. Ich hab mich so gefreut.
Und dein monatelanges Trainieren zu Hause mit dem Aromakasten und denkst dir genau dafür, mach ich. Dein Aromakasten hat es rausgerissen. Yes, wie gut. Moosig. Moos, aber warum ist Moos denn jetzt schlecht? Das wäre noch geiler. Ja, nee, das war eben, habe ich ja auch gesagt. Ich finde es ja geil sogar ein bisschen. Also, Fehlgeschmack Pferd verstehe ich, aber Moos, das ist doch, ja gut. Nee, und dann, das war mosig, hat sie gesagt, und hätte ich das gesagt, wäre die Zehn von Zehn gewesen. Das war ein bisschen mosig, und die probieren es ab, Moos ist der Fehler, und es war irgendwie so ein Naturwein, weiß ich nicht, keine Sulfite drin, das hält in dem Wein länger am Leben, und der hat irgendwie es gekippt über Nacht, so einigermaßen, und das hat so einen mosigen Geruch gemacht. Ich hab's gecallt, Sastin! Ich hab's gecallt! Stefan, ich glaube, du bist ... Also, das ist so, was für ein Kind ist, mit elf den Harry-Potter-Brief zu bekommen, ist für einen Erwachsenen vor anderen Erwachsenen einen Weinfehler zu erschmecken, und der Profi gibt dir Recht und ja, Alter. Wobei, ich bin jetzt bei null, weil ich habe auch schon mal einen Wein durchgewunken, diesen Probierschluck, wo man dann ja immer ein großes Ritual aufführt und das schwenkt und riecht und dann sehr gut. Und dann kam es und dann hat die Begleitung gesagt, ja, nee, der ist verkorkt. Und ich so, ja, weiß ich nicht, ich weiß nicht, wie verkorkt schmeckt. Und dann hat der Kellner das auch nochmal probiert und gesagt, ja, völlig verkorkt. Und dann stand ich halt wie der letzte Idiot da. Oh nein. Jetzt bist du wieder auf null. Jetzt bin ich auf null. Aber das ist die Anadog-Geschichte. Ich glaube, die Leute mögen dich sogar noch mehr, weil man merkt, oh nee, der hat sich jetzt richtig reingehängt. Der ist ja gar nicht so dumm. Das konnte ich mich auch mehr sitzen lassen. Das war so peinlich. Vor allem, weil man natürlich auch so Gender-Klischees aufgesessen ist, weil man natürlich als Mann dann immer den Probierschluck bekommt, was wahnsinnig weird und falsch ist. Und dann kriegt man den und dann versagt man auch noch so auf ganzer Linie. Alles daran war ganz katastrophal, traumatisch. Und jetzt bin ich wieder bei Null mit dieser, es ist eine leichte Aufwärtsgeschichte. Aber ey, ich will dich nicht verleiten, aber es wär spannend. Es wär spannend, es würd dir so eine gewisse ... Wenn du noch so einen Wein, wenn du so einen Sommelierkurs machst, geil, so ein IHK-geprüfter Sommelier, das würd dir so eine gewisse Edge-Ness geben. Ja, ich weiß, aber ich weiß nicht, ich glaub ... Ich versuch ja, weiter ins Tee-Business reinzukommen. Dana mal ganz kurz liebe Grüße an das Reddit Tee. Es macht grossen, grossen Spaß, diesen Kampf zu verfolgen. Genau, Flotin hat letzte Woche von dem Subreddit Tee erzählt, was aber eigentlich das englische Tee für T-Shirts ist. Und es hat irgendwie 500 Mitglieder, die da fleissig über T-Shirts reden. Ein Deutscher hat es aber nicht geschafft, das zu sehen, hat dann damals über Tee gesprochen. Ist Gurgel-Tee zum Verzehr geeignet, ein mittlerweile legendärer Post. Und wir haben letzte Woche aufgerufen zum Putsch, zur friedlichen Übernahme, der Bearhack. Genau, zur subtilen Übernahme zum Tunneln, unter Tunneln dieses Subs. Machen wir es kurz, wir gucken zu viel Succession und wollen irgendwas übernehmen. Wir wollen irgendwas uns einverleiben. Wir wollen uns was einverleiben. Uns soll was gehören. Wir wollen Dealits machen, wir wollen traden, wir wollen den Bearhack. Wir haben den Bearhack, glaube ich, jetzt schon geschafft. Es war alles viel feindlicher, als wir uns, wir hatten uns das als schleichenden Prozess vorgestellt. Ja, es gab aber auch sehr schöne, weil mittlerweile, muss man sagen, gibt es einen Moderatorenpost.
Mittlerweile hat ein Moderator des T--Subredd not the drink tea. Content has to be focused on the clothing, not the drink. Thanks, everyone. Wie geil. Dr. Snoops schreit ein. Nein. Und seitdem mussten sich unsere Angreifer, unsere Saboteure natürlich eine subtilere Taktik überlegen. Und jetzt geht es eher in Richtung T-thematische T-Shirts, weil es geht ja immer noch um T-Shirts und das ist sehr schön. Wir haben aber gesagt, das ist eigentlich die Idee, wir wollen nämlich, dass die Leute gar nicht merken, dass sie plötzlich in einem Tisch... Genau, und auch das Deutsch ist nicht so hilfreich, sondern eher versuchen, es langsam Stück für Stück zu übernehmen. Und das war auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr schön, weil jetzt immer mehr T-Shirt-Ideen mit T kommen, bis hin zu einem T-Rex, der in einer Teetasse auf einem T-Shirt sitzt. Also es hat diverse Abstraktionsgrade erreicht. Ich bin sehr gespannt, in welche Richtung es geht, ob ein Gegenputsch kommt. Ich möchte kurz ... Ich will jetzt niemanden zum Putsch überreden oder so anstiften. Ich möchte nur sagen, es wäre halt hilfreich, wenn einer von euch Moderator werden würde. Und man Doktor Snoops so langsam, also immer mit einer Abfindung, einer gehörigen Abfindung. Absoluten Severance Package. Hey, man, fuck off, man, fuck off, this is ours, okay, this is my dad's, it's mine, fuck off. This is us and you are not us.
Und Dr. Snoops langsam in den wohlverdienten.
He's not family. Dr. Snoops is not family. He doesn't get it.
Also wir haben drei Moderatoren, Dr. Snoops, Flex, Seal, Swift und Will Klein. Will Klein.
Ja, also entweder wir infiltrieren die oder ich glaube, was es jetzt bräuchte, wäre so ein, hey, Dr. Snoops, ich habe gemerkt, dass dein Subreddit Probleme hat. Ich glaube, du brauchst jemanden, der richtig hart durchgreift. Pass auf, ich habe schon einige Subreddits gerettet. Ich bin ein Hardliner. Und genau mich brauchst du jetzt. Ich bin die Bulldogge, die du jetzt brauchst. Es kommen die ganze Zeit Nachrichten rein. Auf Deutsch. Auf dieser Teufelssprache Deutsch. Herr Doktor Snoops. Ich hasse Deutsch. Herr Doktor Snoops, ich verstehe voll und ganz. Ich spreche fliessend Deutsch. Und ich kann mit diesen Leuten reden in einer Sprache, die sie auch verstehen. Es geht um T-Shirts. Ich liebe T-Shirts. T-Shirts sind mein Leben. Sie tragen auch ein T-Shirt. Was trage ich gerade? Ein T-Shirt? Ich liebe T lieben Sie. Alles, was Sie tun müssen. Ich hasse Tee. Sie geben mir... Ich hasse Tee. Was soll das sein? Kaffee ist meins. Aber Tee ist mein Leben. Kaffee ist meins. Gibt's mir jeden Tag. Oder lasst es sein. Hör zu, du kannst den Rest deines Lebens so viel Kaffee trinken wie weh. Nee, wir sind noch ja. Hören Sie zu, alles was ich brauche sind Mordrechte für 24 Stunden und ich räume mit Laden auf. Wir kennen uns erst seit zehn Minuten. Herr Doktor, Sie brauchen jetzt jemanden wie mich, der dazugreift, aber ich vertraue da Ihrem Urteilsvermögen. Okay, komm, ich mach Sie kurz. Ich möchte mich lediglich anbieten. Einen Moment, ich mach Sie da und zack. Sie sind Mord. Warum werde ich rausgeschmissen? Warum bin ich draußen? Warum ist der Begriff, der Betreff des Subreddits plötzlich, es geht um Tee und Tee allein? Dann ist ihr Zugang jetzt gesperrt, Herr Doktor. Nein! Denn schauen Sie mal, welches T-Shirt ich trage. Ein Podcast-Ufo-T-Shirt. Aber hier, ganz kurz, ihr hat ... Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, zoom raus. Die Tram. Dam, dam, dam, da, dam. Doktor Snoops wird rausgeführt von dem Personal, von Sicherheitskräften mit einer Kiste. Und dann gibt es diese Indiana-Jones-End-Szene, wo er in diesen Raum kommt, wo die ganzen anderen Mods sind, von den ganzen Subredits, die wir übernommen. Aber ich, ganz kurzer Shoutout an den Reddit-User oder die Reddit-Userin Ciluzaldilpay. Die hat nämlich, ja, ich klicke furchtbar so nahm, immer auf Reddit. Aber hat ein Shirt gemacht, in unserem Style, also unser Logo, als T-Tasse, als UFO, eine UFO-T-Tasse. Aber ich glaube, das ... Fliegende Untertasse, das passt ja alles zusammen. Aber das wurde dann von der Scam-Site wiederum genommen und in einem Shop angeboten, der Betrug ist. Das gehört jetzt hier nicht hin. Aber nur, ich will nur sagen, dass ... Deine weirden Tangenten sind manchmal nicht angebracht. Ich will nur sagen, dass jede gute Sache auch eine schlechte Nachsicht zieht. Ja, aber wohin führt uns das gerade? Ich möchte nur sagen, lasst eure kreativen Kräfte nicht zu bösen Dingen benutzen, okay? Ihr seid auf der richtigen Seite angekommen. Ich möchte nur jedenfalls, wer hat dieses Design gemacht? Ich kann diesen Namen nicht aussprechen. Bitte wende dich, schreib uns gerne eine Mail an podcast-ufo.fail. Ey, und wir machen so ein T-Shirt. podcast-ufo at zentrale .org zentralepodcast-ufo.fail, unsere E-Mail-Adresse, die wir schon seit acht Jahren benutzen und die immer noch in guter Benutzung ist und uns gute Dienste leistet. Nein, ich wollte ja das Passwort vergessen, das hängt alles im Seiden und Faden, aber ich finde es cool, wenn du dich da mal meldest mit diesem Design, weil das sieht fantastisch aus und ich würde das gerne anbieten im Shop. Ja, und es ist ein witziges Wortspiel, haha, T-Shirt, T,
aber ist nicht zu offensichtlich.
Ja, und die fliegende Untertaste macht ja auch auf eine Art Sinn.
Total, es ist wirklich genial.
Da kommen die Aminosäuren zusammen mit den Tentiden
und dem sauren Milieu.
Da ist alles zusammen.
Das ist einfach so ein Dreiergespann, das einmal alle Jahrhunderte zusammenkommt. Ja, geil. Geile Scheiße. Ich habe Barbecue-Sauce dabei. Okay. Wollen wir auch mal so eine Schlemm-Folge machen? Die habe ich auch. Die kenne ich auch. Ich habe eine Barbecue-Sauce dabei, einfach finde ich immer gut, dabei zu haben im Rucksack. Trinkst du die wie andere, so einen kurzen, so einen Flachmann? Trinkst du zwischendurch den Schluck Barbecue-Support? Ab und zu, ich hab sie im Sakko, ist klar. Aber wenn ab und zu Leute nicht hingucken, ich hab die gerne dabei, weil ich hab mir letztens überlegt, was brauchst du alles im Rucksack. Und ich hab eigentlich immer eine Wasserflasche dabei. Same. Und dann hab ich immer Feuchtigkeitscreme dabei, eine Feile, Deo und eine Powerbank, Ladekabel, Minz, Tick-Zack, du hast auch Airways. Fisherman's Friends habe ich dabei. Und ja, das sind die sieben Sachen. Da dachte ich mir eigentlich, bräuchte man noch so eine Budde-Barbecue-Soße, die man einfach immer dabei hat, die schlecht wird. Die verstehe ich nicht, die passen nicht so ganz für mich da rein. Die einfach immer, ich finde das, egal wo du bist, in welchem Restaurant, in welcher Situation, kannst du immer deine eigene Barbecue-Sauce auspacken, du hast immer welche dabei und das ist eigentlich immer gut. Sehr unsympathisch, aber es passt zur Folge, ich habe immer einen Weinöffner dabei. Oh, schön! Weil daran ist nämlich auch ein kleines Messer, daran ist auch ein Bieröffner, also ein ganz normaler Flaschenöffner und weil es kommt schon mal vor, dass man irgendwo eine Korkflasche hat und dann kriegt man die nicht auf. Und deswegen habe ich mein... Du meinst aber nicht jetzt diesen Hampelmann, oder? Der mit diesen Armen oder so? Nee, nee, einen richtigen so einen Gastro Weinöffner. Wahnsinn. Aber ist es nicht auch cool, wenn man dann irgendwie so... Also, jetzt mal ganz kurz, wir kennen uns jetzt nicht so gut mit Coolness aus. aber angenommen so irgendwie, speak for your fucking self, man, hey man, okay, aber angenommen man ist jetzt irgendwie mit den Jungs unterwegs und es ist alles richtig cool und so und dann hat jemand eine Flasche Wein, so, ah, lass uns weinen, oder irgendwie so, okay, pass auf, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Gruppe Jugendliche, Sitz am Rhein, gute Laune und plötzlich so schaut jemand auf die Uhr, hey, es ist schon nach null Uhr, hey, Olli, du hast doch Geburtstag, happy birthday, let's go, hey, ich habe eine Flasche Wein dabei, okay, geil, lass uns Wein trinken, oh, kein Flaschenöffner.
Eben, eben.
Wer ist jetzt cooler, pass auf, wer ist jetzt cooler, der, der sagt, ich kann die mit einem Schuh aufmachen, oder der, der einen Weinöffner dabei hat, also der, der improvisieren kann, der MacGyver, oder der, der, ich hab jemandem was dabei, ich hab auch einen Erster Hilfekasten dabei.
Also falls irgendwas passiert, ist das vielleicht nicht unkul, wenn du zu gut vorbereitet bist.
Das meine ich auch. Also ich mach's nicht aus Coolnessgründen oder sowas.
Und ich glaube, du hast recht, der MacGyver ist immer der beliebteste Guy, aber ich hab einen richtigen Weinöffner dabei,
weil ich das nicht mit dem Stuhl aufmachen kann und das nicht aus Coolnessgründen mache, sondern einfach aus Praktikabilitätsgründen. Macht mich das nicht cool, weiß ich wohl auch. Macht mich eher unsympathisch. Man hat da so zwei Stufen vom Hebel, ne? Man macht erst den ersten ein und dann hat man noch eine zweite Ebene, man kann noch mal weiter raufhebeln. Der ist wirklich fantastisch. Das ist schon cool. Nee, das mache ich gern. Und wird mir halt immer zum Verhängnis beim Flugzeug, bei der Sicherheitskontrolle. Ja. Vergesse ich das, dass man kein Messer mit reinnehmen kann. Dann muss ich es mal ausklappen, dann ist es aber immer okay. Und dann kriegst du im Flugzeug eine Flasche Wein serviert. Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. Wines on the plane. Die boring, boring Fortsetzung für Snacks on the plane. Also, falls ihr jetzt gerade kein konkretes Bild vor Augen habt, als Stefan gesagt hat, da ist ein Messer dran, meinte er mit ein winziges drei Zentimeter Klinglein, mit der er am Ende wahrscheinlich um sein Leben kämpfen muss, wenn er im tibetanischen Dschungel von einer Würgeschlange langsam aufgefressen wird und sich versucht, mit seinem Weinöffner rauszuarbeiten.
Glaubst du, eine Schlange ist A, sehr beeindruckt, B, weniger beeindruckt oder C, gar nicht beeindruckt, wenn ich dir so ein Messerchen in die Seite, die Flanke reibe.
Ich glaube, das ist ja scheißegal.
Ja?
Ich glaube, also das Messer, also ich glaube, die hat mehr Angst davor, von dem Flaschenöffner aufgehebelt zu werden.
Weil wir als Mensch haben ja verschiedene
Zonen, wo wir unterschiedlich empfindlich sind,
wo die Nervenenden unterschiedlich sind.
Jetzt hast du als Schlange
sehr viel gleich. Gleichmässig.
Alles sehr gleichmässiges Tier.
Unfassbar langweilig, kann man auch sagen.
Also wenig erotisch.
Also es gibt weniger...
Das finde ich gar nicht.
Ich meine, so erogene Zonen oder so, wo du mal so spielen kannst mit, ist bei einer Schlange einfach alles da, oder nicht? Ja. Also angenommen, eine Schlange würde, sagen wir mal, ein Bikini tragen. What you see is what you get. Und das ist ja das Gegenteil von Erotik. Erotik heißt ja immer ... Das Gegenteil von der Schnecke zum Beispiel. You don't see it and you don't know what you can. Und das Gegenteil von der Schnecke. Eine Schnecke ist das erotischste Tier. Ja klar, die ist in ihrem Haus. Muschel ist ... Hot. Alles passiert in deinem Kopf. Alles passiert nur in deinem Kopf. Genau. Und dann kommt es raus und man denkt ... Oh Gott, das ist eine Muschel. Ich wusste nicht, dass ein Tier da drin ist. Ich habe jetzt auch diese Dokuserie über Dinosaurier geschaut, Prehistoric Times. Ja, auf Apple Plus auch. Genau, was anscheinend, ja. David Attenborough macht so eine ganz klassische Tierdoku, aber halt über Tiere, die es nicht gibt, die halt mit CGI animiert sind. Aber so typisch dieses, das Baby-Nah-Sorn folgt der Mutter und am Ende ist alles gut, denn sie haben sich wiedergefunden.
Da ist er gerade noch mal mit dem Leben davongekommen.
Genau.
Er lebt einen weiteren Tag, doch der Tod kommt von oben, ein Adler packt.
Und das Tolle ist, dass die auch so das zu inszenieren, als wäre die Kamera jetzt hinter so einem Blatt oder als müsste man die erst finden, obwohl die da alle animiert sind. Aber es ist schon ein bisschen komisch, diese Doku zu schauen, weil es ist ja alles nur geraten, weil die sagen ja nicht nur, okay, das sind die Dinos eins, zwei, drei, sondern dann zeigen die halt so ein Balzritual von so einem Flugdinosaurier, wie der halt da so ein Nest baut, um das Weibchen anzuhören. Du denkst mir, das hat sich alles jemand ausgedacht. Das kann man doch nicht. Wir wissen ja nicht mal, wie die aussahen. Wir diskutieren ja immer noch darüber, wie dick die Lippen vom T-Rex waren. Richtig, keine einzige dicke Lippe gesehen in der ganzen Doku, nichts. Wobei die meine ich schon den Anspruch hatte, einigermassen, also klar, die animieren das seit 20 Jahren, aber bei Redaktionsschluss vor dieser Animationssache,
da haben die, glaube ich, schon sich auf die neuesten wissenschaftlichen Studien gezogen. Da kommt er wahrscheinlich aus, dass du da studierst.
Fall mal auf hier.
Hier, ihr Computer-Nerds hier.
Guck mal, ich habe hier in der Zeitung gelesen, dass der T-Rex ...
Sie rauchen einen Toast Hawaii?
Ja klar, natürlich.
Sie wollen Doppelkrebs.
Wenn schon, denn schon, sage ich immer.
Mach denen mal hier Lippen und hier Trompeten auf die Ohren.
Hier, nächste Woche ist Release.
Nächste Woche ist Release.
Gib denen nochmal so Schlappen an den Beinen.
Okay.
Mach denen nochmal hier so, der eine hat so ein pinkes Kettenhemd an, hab ich gelesen. Kettenhemd, pink, Sir, Sir, Sir, das geht alles nicht mehr. Ach, tippt das da in deinen Computer ein, tippt das da ein. Ich bezahl euch nicht dafür, dass ihr mir sagt, ihr könnt das nicht. Ich bezahl euch dafür, dass ihr Ja sagt, ja, und dann ascht der so auf dem Laptop. Jesus Christ. Okay, was ... Solche Leute Tierdokus machen, aber auch das sind so die richtigen Geldbonzen einfach, die Geldsäcke mit Zigarren. Aber so stelle ich mir ... Eigentlich ist es doch immer so, dass Leute, von denen man es am wenig am meisten erwartet, wie zum Beispiel Spielzeughersteller, die stelle ich mir genau so vor. Das ist das richtige Arschlöcher. So kleine Ritterburgen oder der Furby-Erfinder ist so ein ... Guck mich an, okay? Wenn ich mit dir spreche, guckst du mit den Augen! Okay, alles klar. Okay. Okay, es schreckt deine Hand aus. Es schreckt deine Hand aus. Und dann drückt er die Zerrette auf der Hand aus. Es tut mir leid. Und im Hintergrund die Riesenhalle mit Furbys, die alle sagen ... Nein, nein, nein, Peter me, Peter me. Es tut mir leid, wir konnten jetzt leider den Furby-Tanz nicht vollständig ... Also er wird wahrscheinlich zu, der Furby-Tanz, sie hatten ja den Hula-Tanz vorgeschlagen. Security, Security. Nein, bitte nicht, nein, ich wollte nur sagen, ah, ah, ah, ah, er verdient seinen Namen, ah. Und im Mittagessen so eine Masse an Furbys, die so, Furby, Furby, weißt du, wenn,, wenn oder so Schmerzgriff, alle Furbies. Ja, weil die klingen ja, wenn man die einzelnen sich anhört, süss. Schmerzgriff, Schmerzgriff, aber wie halt alle Dinge werden halt Stimmen gruselig, wenn es halt eine Riesenmasse macht. Ja, Schmerzgriff, diese Orks. Batterien auswechseln, Batterien auswechseln. So diese Halle einfach. Weil diese, wenn Saruman zum ersten Mal mit Grima Schlangenzunge, schöner Name. But my lord, there is no such army. Genau, guter, starker Name, Grima Schlangenzunge. Gehen raus auf den Balkon, auf den schönen Balkon, Westbalkon. Sonnenseitenbalkon, Dachterrasse, gehen raus und sehen halt diese riesen Uruk-Army. Und dann habe ich gelesen, das war irgendwie so ein Fussballstadion, was sich Peter Jackson irgendwie gemietet hat. Die verbotene Sprache Mordor, der hat ein ganzes Stadion gezwungen. Und direkt abgestiegen, der Feind direkt abgestiegen. Verbotene Sprache. Die spielen jetzt in der dritten Liga. Ja, ja, die ist richtig abgestürzt. Ist ja niemand gestorben? Nein, aber die spielen jetzt in der dritten fucking Liga. Das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen. Mordor, Mordors Sprache. Ja, THC Mordor, einfach so. THC! Oder weißt du, was auch immer. Aber, Schwefel, Säure, Mordor. Aber jetzt erklär du mir mal, wie ist Griemer Schlangenzunge in den Turm gekommen, ohne die Armee zu sehen. Warum hat er die noch nicht gesehen? Weil die sich alle hinter Bäumen versteckt haben. Da hat er die nicht schon gesehen. Das ist einfehler. Die haben gekichert? Ich hab das im Filmfehler vor. Nee, weil er das nicht gehört hat. Der hat die gesehen, er musste die gesehen haben. Als er dir hingeritten ist, du den... So stelle ich mir dich bei Inas Nacht vor. Wenn du da zum ersten Mal ein Bier tritt... Der hat die immer Schlangenzunge, der hat den gesehen, der kann die nicht gesehen haben. Sorry, Ihre Bestellung bitte. Ich hab dir gesagt, dass du den Schlangenzongel, den Schlangenzongel, der musstest ja haben. So bin ich nach einem Glas Rotwein. Wenn wir zusammen in die Bar gehen. Stell dich mir vor, wenn du so bei Inas Nacht eingeladen bist und dann kriegst du so ein Bier hingestellt, so Radler hingestellt, das trinkst du dann, weil du dir nicht traust zu sagen, das trinkst du nicht und dann cut und dann schalte ich so um, guck Ditsche oder so, dann schalte ich wieder um und du bist da so, okay, mein Schatten, nee, Katapultvermörder, das könnte ja gar nicht so, weiss, und das zeigt sich eigentlich gar nicht, die Gondor hätte nicht, die, auch so die Fliege, so, oder deine Krawatte ist so verschoben, ja, ganz offen, ja, aber das, ja, nee, aber das ist halt, und Menschen sprechen ja wie wir. Die rufen halt Ach mal, Lelo oder was auch immer diese verbotene Sprache. Ich will sie jetzt nicht aussprechen. Was sagt das über unseren Podcast? Da müssen wir extra markieren, enthält verbotene Sprache. Trigger-Warnung, verbotene Sprache. Und wir rufen halt alle auch so mit unseren Stimmchen Hallo, hallo, hi, hi, hi, Mensch, Mensch, Mensch. Ja. Und das sind halt keine Uruk-hai, aber diese Masse an Menschen klingt dann halt doch gefährlich. Da waren auch Kinder dabei. Nein, das glaube ich nicht. Doch, klar waren da Kinder dabei, in so einem Stadion in Neuseeland. Ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche, haut rein und wir sehen uns dann nächste Woche wieder, wenn es weitergeht mit einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast-Ufo-Projektchen.
Drei, sechs, eins
dann. Nehmt euch in acht. Es geht immer
weiter. Nicht verbotener Sparung sprechen. Tschaui!
Tschau! Mh! Easy Credit Plus App auszahlen. Er muss keinen neuen Kredit abschliessen. Macht's wie Siggi. Finanziert ganz entspannt. Mit Easy Credit.